so i want to pull this other story from
elon musk about his his uh his his plans
for a legal effort but we're talk we got
to talk about solutions to
you know what's happening with politics
cultural stuff hearing you guys mention
that you're giving grants to people like
just no strings attached no equity just
you know do the work basically is that
what you're saying yeah if you're
working on something cool yeah one of
the big challenges when we look at
project veritas james o'keefe comes out
he says be brave
we've got
obviously at these companies their
censorship obviously they're not being
honest we just had this expose where
there's this in this uh this engineer at
a twitter talking to his date saying oh
yeah they're censoring the right all the
time
why are these people not coming out and
being like yo they're lying when they go
to congress and say these things they're
lying under oath
i think one of the reasons is they're
scared many people say they say it all
the time i got kids man
i can't i can't just up and dip
so
i often talk about infrastructure being
a key element to you know getting away
from silicon valley so rumble for
instance i'm a fan uh we use their video
player for the website members only
section and we use their cloud services
for our website and we're integrating
more
non-silicon valley infrastructure into
the website we have more plans we'll
announce those as soon as we have them
ready
to create competition to push back
that's another big move
if people are going to be able to blow
the whistle and come out and just give
maybe it's not james o'keefe maybe it's
any news organization and be like here's
documents proving it there has to be a
place for them to exist there there has
to be something telling them you can
find work you can be supported you will
not be thrown to the wolves just by
coming out you're not sacrificing
yourself doing the right thing actually
could benefit you it actually can be
really great for your career all of a
sudden you'll be getting a better job
but i want to pull up this tweet thread
from elon musk from the 20th check this
out
he says tesla is building a hardcore
litigation department where we directly
initiate and execute lawsuits the team
will report directly to me please send
three to five bullet points describing
evidence of exceptional ability justice
tesla.com he says my commitment we will
never seek victory in a just case
against us even if we probably win even
if we will probably win we will never
surrender settle an unjust case against
us even if we will probably lose please
include links to cases you have tried he
says looking for hardcore street
fighters not white shoe lawyers like
perkins or cooley who thrive on
corruption there will be blood
it sounds like he was watching the show
last night
yeah we do well four days ago oh nice
this is this is from four days this is
the sentiment man we need lawyers that
are willing to lose that are willing to
take a chance
this is what one of the things that
frustrates me in in all the the
conversations are people saying there's
oh don't i i've every single time i've
been defamed every time there's been
some question of section 230 every
lawyer i've spoken with has been like
there's no point in trying
don't do it
elon musk certainly has the funds to be
like don't know don't care here's the
money have fun
that's what we need we need real
solutions to all of these issues that
are happening so i'm curious what you
guys think about the legal side of
things in terms of suing or going after
you know we we had talked privately
about section 230
i mean i'll defer to ian here who's a
lawyer by training i'm a lawyer by
training i no longer practice so i won't
give direct legal takes but i mean
obviously uh litigation is a huge part
of this you know we just had the um the
fifth circuit rule um in a preliminary
motion in the uh lawsuit to enjoin uh
the um
social media law they passed that could
have a huge impact there's a similar
case on with a similar but not quite as
powerful law in florida that's on i mean
these things are
important in themselves but they're also
the culmination of at this point really
five or six years of litigation around
this very issue around 230 around free
speech around um the power of social
media networks and so on um
and he's absolutely right the entire
industry is coalesced around this you
have these industry associations that
are spending a large amount of money on
lawyers to fight because they do know
how how impactful it could be and you
know at fudo we're not directly involved
in any litigation you know we kind of
are focused on the technology side but
we know that it is a multi-pronged uh
fight and that those uh those lawsuits
are very important how do you feel about
copyright law from the past being used
in future tech like with social media
technology and things like that
well okay i'm going to differ on
intellectual property law in particular
because he has some but i'll just say
that that's been an issue from uh for 25
years the very first political issue i
ever remember being engaged in when i
was what nine years old or something was
you know the dmca had just passed uh and
if you remember a dcss uh was a um
uh a very very simple piece of software
that allowed you to decode a dvd on on a
device without having paid the license
fee for a dvd player uh and this was one
of the first things that they went after
as a copy uh copyright breaking tool
under the dmca which allowed you to shut
it down
and that i mean right there is a um is a
huge that is a use of a copyright
enforcement mechanism uh to um
limit the freedom and you know not
necessarily just to protect a copyright
holder but to go after the entire
universe of of freely flowing tech of
information and so on and i think that's
a principle that extends more broadly
the same technology that's used to
enforce copyright or intellectual
property can and often is used
to enforce
restrictions on free speech on the flow
of information and on the use of
technology in general
that's one of the big challenges with uh
the copyright stuff that has happened
with social media is i had i had a tweet
that was absolutely fair you just get
taken down under copyright and what do
you do
there the the challenge is that i kind
of feel like no matter what you do the
person with the most power wins
if you've got the money you're gonna win
that's just about it i mean maybe you
might get lucky and and get a good judge
and fight your way through
but you know even in the instance of
james o'keefe fighting defamation cases
he needs to raise like a million two
million dollars to even try to go after
these these big companies and then you
just have the courts are always you know
often siding with the people who are
defaming or the big tech or the
establishment or something like that
this is one of the biggest challenges
that it feels like
even
it feels like fighting an uphill battle
because
uh we you know i've talked about
wikipedia quite a bit
how fractured the system is how it makes
literally no sense but they have so much
money
how do you compete with that as an
individual it just doesn't seem to make
sense you need capital that's for sure
because it's like a war of attrition in
court you it's it's how long can i pay
all these lawyers to stay in this
courthouse and keep talking no one
really cares if they win or lose they're
all getting paid as long as you've got
the money to pay them so you either need
people to work for free which is a form
of capital or money social currency
getting a lot of people who believe in
you just to to you know focus fire their
efforts and their and their labor
towards something more powerful i guess
i wanna i wanna i wanna mention an idea
to you so uh ian you're you're a lawyer
by training i want to ask your thoughts
on this
what if we made a uh
a website
where as soon as you load it you are
placed in a queue where you can write
one word
and 5 000 people all write one word
who's sued for defamation when you write
a story claiming that nancy pelosi eats
dogs
it's a tough one i see what you're
getting in here that you know what
you're running there's an interactive
computer service which is protected from
defamation under uh you know cda section
two each individual made no statement
right writing the word dog i didn't say
anything all i wrote was dog you can't
sue me can you
it's a very interesting like that could
be a good
law school hypothetical right
we need some coders
if you're a developer we're going to
create this interactive website
where uh it starts with a queue i
mentioned this the other day and then
everyone from you from your position you
know you like if you're the first person
in your number one you get the first
word well just let everybody like fork
it whenever they want and you'll be
guaranteed to get whatever whatever
you want and then as an editor you could
pick the one that you want to show
exactly and then we'll feature whichever
one that comes up so you might have an
article that says like nancy pelosi run
jump car drive fast and you're just like
that's nonsense and then you'll finally
get one that says nancy pelosi ate a dog
because people just did oh like mad libs
yeah kind of digital madness every
single word
what if you tell them this has to be a
verb then are you all sudden an editor
then you'll get sued because you're
telling them to write a verb or a noun
because that'll help it that's
interesting
i think we're onto something i mean what
if i wrote nancy pelosi what if we did
an actual ad-lib where you know mad lib
or whatever it's called where it's like
nancy pelosi blanked a blank and then
some random person could put a word and
i didn't write the sentence right i put
blanks someone else put it can you would
i be able to be sued for defamation
uh
i'm i'm not definitely not an expert in
defamation law it seems it seems like a
difficult case to me you know it's going
to hinge in a lot of things that but
yeah
it's interesting i mean the problem is
your your website would be hard for you
to get enough clout for your website for
people to you know
believe
what it said as opposed to wikipedia
where it kind of has a lot of clout now
sure sure i just think you know we'll be
allowed to post all of this stuff sure
like i'll put it on twitter to a million
1.3 million people and let them share it
and then what is anyone going to say to
me they're going to be like you can't
say that and i'll be like i'm just
sharing a story from you know people
you can't sue me for it it's not my i'll
i'll tweet it out and i'll put what a
crazy story right
and then everyone will see the headline
and uh
and then what what can i do about it
there's a question whether it's
definitely like if it is a website where
these things truly are random people
posting words i think there's some
question as to whether it is actually
even if it is something nasty that comes
up eventually uh as to whether it is
like defamation you know as opposed to
uh people would not take it and if no
one would take it as such you know um
you know there's a certain point at
which it's obviously satire and not
meant as a statement
what if i only allowed
a handful of words
like nancy
pelosi
eats and dog
dog eats nancy pelosi you sure yeah yeah
whatever whatever whatever combination
of the words love you nancy i'm just
kidding what if it turns out to be true
that's the real
that's the
yeah you got to be careful i don't know
i'm crying i'm joking but i mean i just
i look at what's going on with big tech
and how they're basically invincible how
they have these laws that for us we get
spat on we get pissed on we get stepped
on
and then wikipedia can just do whatever
the hell they want
that that that can't be that that just
cannot be it's when it says from
wikipedia that it starts to get real
fishy for me like if it was if they were
clear like this is all community and
they they linked to the the screen names
of the people that put the little pieces
in and stuff that's a different story
except
someone could write on wikipedia nancy
pelosi eats chicken
another person can go in and change
chicken to dog and they've made no
statement you can't sue that person
because they've made no statement the
person who said she eat chicken maybe
that's true the person who changed
chicken a dog did not make a statement
he just said the word dog you can't sue
someone for saying a single word there's
no defamation there wikipedia needs to
be sued into oblivion because it is them
they have automated the editorial
process under their own byline and this
this argument that their protect under
section 230 makes absolutely no sense
you know what
we need so uh how do we how do we do
this do we set up a go well go give send
go raise a couple million bucks find
someone with standing and say have fun
is that is that allowed is that legal i
mean you've had i mean my my preference
would be to solve this technically and
like build a better product than
wikipedia
but it's it's
see i i just i disagree i think culture
is the issue
that
regular people know wikipedia use
wikipedia google has integrated
wikipedia and every facet this machine
is here and they are clearly violating
at the very least the spirit of the law
but i believe technically like at a
technical standpoint they're they're you
know totally open to being sued someone
just needs to
do it
where's james o'keefe someone called me
called children
i mean there's been lawsuits right so i
mean
they happen and wikipedia will settle
i just we need wikipedia will change it
even if i have to feel they have to well
they should change it i mean that's the
goal right get him to change it so they
stop allowing this because right now
i do not understand how wikipedia can
can publish such false statements i mean
look the the project veritas article
wikipedia is clearly an opinion piece
it's it's outrageous how how much
opinion it is
they they're this that or otherwise and
conspiracies and it's it's loaded with
fake news it's loaded with provenly
false claims
and it's from wikipedia james you gotta
sue maybe we shouldn't be able to have
people on wikipedia they shouldn't you
shouldn't be able to have a person's
page or a corporation's page on
wikipedia because like in
encyclopedia britannica they didn't have
like people it would just be things
well i mean you had i think i think
there's maybe no living people at some
point i'm not actually sure about that
but i think maybe at some point it was
no living people but i i could be wrong
okay
i just i mean you've had larry singer on
i mean he's working on this we're we're
actually futo is did a grant for his
organization to try to fix this
i i i kind of agree with you like like
wikipedia owns the culture right now and
like
it's hard to solve like still like you
know this is a hard work and like as
future as a tech organization we want to
try to create technical solutions i do
feel like there is some ways we can chip
away at wikipedia clearly free speech
has already
weakened their stature in the culture
there's many people who like know that
wikipedia's propaganda
on any kind of contentious issue what i
would like to see as from the technical
solution would be some sort of way for
dissenting editors at wikipedia to very
very easily fork it and have their own
kind of wiki have their own articles
show up and have you know
building this product is one of the
trickier i consider wikipedia to be a
very special case of social media it's
crowdsourced it's a bunch of editors
like you said making dips to articles
right but it still is very much you know
crowdsourced from millions of people or
hundreds of thousands of people it all
comes in
how can we get get it so that like
those contributions are more
uh ubiquitous for the world and like
different editors can decide different
editor organizations can decide who
which editor should be banned and what
shouldn't and the dissenting side in any
kind of these wikipedia edit wars
actually has
a viable thing that people will find and
that's that's those are the sort of
things that larry's working on
with his his organization you could have
like a page with all these overlays that
would pop up with different percentages
of how accurate or each overlay relative
to these editors like if an editor has a
72 percent rating then they're gonna
affect their overlay that they edited
and then you'd be able to sort all the
overlays on like dog the wikipedia's
thing of like hillary clinton or
whatever right and then so you'd see
like 900 000 hillary clinton wikipedia
pages on top of each other and then
you'd sort them by the ones with the
most trusted editors and you sort that
one to the top
maybe i think the issue is the most
trusted editors would be 50 50 if that
right so
i i once i was talking with a group of
people way back in the day about a
journalist rating system or a news
organization rating system one of the
things we want to do with our our fact
checking nonprofit is create a browser
extension and then actually hire the
higher fact checkers to do to rate
various news outlets based on violations
of journalistic ethics one of the ideas
has always been what if you create a
meter showing like how much do we trust
a journalist
okay well if they write for breitbart
they're going to get a zero right
because every mainstream every liberal
democrat person is going to be like liar
liar liar liar liar at best you could
hope for 50 50. but that means
you need like
if i came out
and said joe biden uh is corrupt
you know has engaged in overt corruption
with the ukraine scandal saying fire the
prosecutor i mean that is a statement of
fact
when they claimed that donald trump was
trying to get a quid pro quo in ukraine
joe biden did literally that going going
to the president saying fire the
prosecutor or you're not getting a
billion dollars in loan guarantees
that's exactly what they claimed it was
so it's corruption he's just not been
held accountable for it if i say that
people on the left are going to say
either knowingly
that uh or i should say that willfully
they'll call me a liar knowing it's true
because they want political power so
let's say oh that story from tim pool is
false minus one then you're gonna get a
bunch of other democrats and antifa
types are gonna be like that's not true
i heard on cnn minus one
you're hoping then that if a thousand of
these people right down rate you
that some conservative who knows it's
true is going to uprate you or at the
very least you'll end up with
conservatives saying i believe that's
true whether it is or not it's going to
be the inverse version of the same thing
so we need a trustless way to identify
their value um maybe if people don't
realize they're rating the articles or
the individuals that edit the articles
but they're they're either maybe with
with crypto
um i like the trustless
smart i contracts i'm kind of throwing
up buzzwords here i gotta i got to be a
little more uh pessimistic though i
think the issue is culture it doesn't
matter if you're gonna say a journalist
is trusted or not what matters is what
the culture wants believes and expects
and right now we have two very distinct
cultures in this country that will never
come together i think it's natural
resistance is natural human um evolution
it's part of our evolution our nature
you'll always have people saying that
you're wrong and always at people saying
you're right for the most part things
are things are different i mean it used
to be that there were democrats and
republicans they'd argue with each other
but they were all americans they'd all
come out for the fourth of july and be
like oh you know i don't agree with that
stuff but hey america america right
now you've got people
that cnn for instance all these big news
outlets know for a fact they're never
going to sell to a trump supporter so
they have absolutely zero reason to be
honest about trump and his supporters
if they know their bread is being
buttered by a bunch of you know left
activists
why would they ever tell the truth on
trump
i mean right now jim acosta you know he
did a segment the other day where he
claimed donald trump appears to have
been calling for civil war
which is just bs it's not true trump
retweeted basically a guy who said the
words civil war i don't know what that
means it's like you you on the news
story here's the facts
donald trump reposts
comment that says civil war that's it
take for it what you will that's the
fact the opinion is was he calling for
it was he predicting it was he scared i
have no idea but jim acosta see it and
all these big mainstream outlets say
he's either calling for it or predicting
it that's not true none of that is true
that's all opinion but they know
there's no one for the most part who is
buying from them for truth
everybody wants their their confirmation
bias everyone no matter where you come
from now i think there's a tendency more
so on the right to associate with those
who are right
you know post liberals moderates
libertarians conservatives whatever the
freedom spaces
you have more people who are like no no
just tell me what's true
the left for the most part has gone full
zealot as far as i can tell
i don't like the word true truth anymore
i used to be a zealot about what was
true and i'd be like it is this the one
true something and i was like come on
iam you don't know like get over
yourself and also the word trust i don't
think humans trust each other we're wild
animals we've domesticated each other we
kind of sit in peace together with like
pretending like we know we're not going
to hurt each other but like doesn't mean
it's never going to happen you know so
we live in this idea of truth and trust
which is just like
100 percent they're extremes that don't
exist and so we should code our stuff
that way too and trust can be can be in
a way kind of productive let me explain
that just briefly the um i talked to
several people who grew up you know
behind the iron curtain and what they
always say about that is you know we
knew our news was fake we knew the
newspapers were nonsense but uh and in a
way that's that's sort of because there
was no trust they knew that okay you
have to read between the lines you have
to really think about this
in this uh in this country um for better
or for worse we used to have much more
trust in media and our institutions i
think part of that is technological you
know that we had an era where the the
main means of media distribution were
the broadcast television channels a few
major newspapers that were sort of
had a a legal interest in being
i i don't want to use the word objective
that that strongly but uh new more
neutral
um and we don't have that and we sort of
carried over this uh unwarranted trust
and as that's that's broken down i think
people look at things even even
wikipedia i think with a with a more
skeptical eye
um
and you know if you can shore that up
the people's uh you know you can find
things that people can trust i think you
do you do a service
i like well i think trustless they talk
about like um like smart contracts
crypto smart contracts are trustless
because you don't have to trust that
giving your money to the guy he's gonna
do the thing that you gave him the money
to do it just automatically happens so
you remove that that level of trust
um like i get like trusting your parents
if you don't trust your parents i mean
the world's gonna seem like it wants to
kill you every moment you're you're
living in it but if you can trust your
parents it's still like doesn't mean
they're never gonna turn on you but it's
just like
an acceptance like when i step and my
foot's not going to go through the
ground i trust that i'm going to land on
solid ground
um i guess it's just not an ideal like
like
what do we have to trust something every
individual should be allowed to decide
on their own who they trust right i mean
based on what parameters everybody gets
to decide through their interactions
with them right it's not we can't have a
top-down approach to trust where we're
told to trust certain people i kind of
feel like there there may be an
inevitability in the hyper polarization
though i think it's possible that the
tech oligarchs the censorship has
exacerbated this by banning only some
people
i kind of feel like
we saw early on in the internet
tribes were forming where people like to
rag on each other there's a video that i
talk about often called this video will
make you angry by cgp gray where he
mentions that communities don't actually
argue with each other they argue amongst
themselves about the other and they get
riled up and get angrier and angrier
about it and this tribalism eventually
leads to conflict so i wonder if
if
do you think that's an inevitability
in in it with the internet i mean the
culture war itself arising out of these
tribes that have former everyone hates
each other i mean yeah i mean human
nature we see it with sports teams
everything like it's an it's inevitable
but
doesn't
how do you stop it from getting to the
point where people are killing each
other this this is a philosophical point
but i think that um yes if you do have
uh i don't know if you call it a free
market for but if you do have uh
different groups able to trust who they
want uh and and able to to use an
alternative technology when they want to
get the information they do i think that
you have
i understand that that can lead to
problems but i think it leads to fewer
problems than one of uh like you say
this top-down enforcement of trust where
inevitably one tribe or one side or
another is going to feel this intense
resentment uh i think that's when things
get really dangerous when people
are confirmed in their belief that
they're that
everything is against them thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there
you